did you know that this iconic Goku fit
is not just a silly Japanese pun but the
origin of an entire holiday that's right
this extremely cool jacket which I
constantly wish I could buy because
let's be honest it looks sick Sports the
number 59 on it which to us foolish
English speakers doesn't really mean
much but for the original Japanese
audience it's actually a funny little
joke you see in Japanese the number five
is called go and as you may be able to
gather at this point then the number
nine is called coup so five nine would
be called Goku in Japanese see haha very
funny but this is also why May 9th since
the Japanese expressed their calendar
dates in evil year month day order May
9th becomes the official Goku day but
wait I thought that was Piccolo dick
Dragon Ball you need to sort out your
holiday situation